hi the next thing I see actually still
has to do with the picture it's like
here and it's kind of its kind of here
as well kinda hmm what do you think the
issue between these two the vesting
that's a pretty broad okay what kinds of
things well what is this by the way
cannot see it make it up yeah there's a
facebook like on Twitter I cover it what
kind of issue do you think is here and
it's not privacy because we already
talked about that this is kind of like a
like privacy and like what's the matter
looking for status security in that kind
of thing and this is a really easy one
to go for okay emerging trends what is
emerging trends mean it just means as an
issue there's new kinds of technologies
coming up and they affect people that's
all that's all it means okay the imagine
turns out looking at here are the
relationship between real estate and
social media okay now be careful here
okay a lot of people talk to that
emerging trends but they are overstated
their case morning and this this comma
began in changing nature of work okay
some people said are the emergency here
is you can do all of your you know your
real estate research and that kind of
thing you can do all of this stuff
online now so now no one ever is going
to go see a real estate agent in person
ever again because why would you ever
have to no one's going to go to open
homes anymore Oh grams just going to
stop they're going to cease existing
right now I think that's overstepping
like a little bit if anything I mean
here's here's the comparator i like to
make for you okay when itunes was first
introduced now you guys don't really
know a world without itunes but it was
this big thing when it was like wow
Apple is going to sell individual songs
um with no physical sort of thing behind
them to anyone who wants from their home
okay now what kind of arguments along
these lines teaching people may when
they're like oh my goodness Apple is
going to destroy the music industry what
do you think people are saying
no one is going to buy CDs ever again
there's no people aren't going to get
like albums at all because you can just
get the one or two songs that you like
off the album not mean to ignore the
rest of the trash vs. like I don't
really like those kinds of soldier in
this artists I just want these one or
two that are the cleaner off the sink or
something like that people predicted the
death of the music industry now to be
fair a lot of like you know HMV's and
Saturdays and those kinds of stores have
shut down but despite that trend people
are buying more music now than ever more
cds than ever despite the fact that
people can buy them without cds okay now
you can go and think about your own
reasons as to why that's the case you
know there's still something to be said
about whole your CD and opening it up
and like oh there's my favorite band
which you don't get the same kind of
from you know hitting download on iTunes
but similar kind of thing here ok so my
issue is emerging trends okay and you
can talk about real estate now being
propagated out through social media
those kinds of things but don't say it's
that it's the end of all you know real
world interaction a bit we're just going
to stay in their homes and no one's of
people just going to click buy instead
of on lines that have actually gone into
a house or an office in like that
okay it's not like that okay let's keep
on marching down a little bit okay
there's not all that much that's
interesting they're taking photographs
heading that's more kind of like the
technical details which were part of
question a but under image precious you
okay this should raise some questions
all images are digitally processed to
enhance their appearance do you need
evening meal what's the issue what would
you call it has a name okay you can
either go for integrity or accuracy both
are fine I think in this case accuracy
might be a better sort of like a more
specific issue because it's not so much
about you know this is power issue it's
not so much as there's some data missing
right um but that the data there it's
not it's not exactly what was taken off
the picture even then what was taken off
the picture is not exactly what's there
okay so you've got the issue of look
they're admitting yeah we my girl yeah
muck around with it for sure because we
want to make it look better well I don't
know if you've ever you should go and do
this afterwards can go and find go look
up like real estate com that I you okay
and go to look up some photography need
to be this fancy you know surround 3d
experience kind of thing go look at the
pictures try and find some homes or
houses knew where you live and a similar
to the kinds of house that you live in
okay go and have a look at the pictures
and you'll find their radically
different to the actual house that you
live and you like this house is just
like my it but it looks fantastic and
wine looks like a dump okay why did I do
that there's all kinds of it would fix
things like you know mucking around with
the lighting using a lens which is why
which makes things look really big even
if they're actually quite small things
like that okay so data accuracy big
issue okay still within image processing
surround pics files are created using
proprietary software quick question to
be greater their proprietary what's it
mean what synonyms could you like what
would you substitute in there
could have used the web proprietary what
would you say instead they've actually
ask another question first raise your
hand if you know what the word
proprietary means hands up okay so can I
get a dictionary out at home you kind of
you need the the sentence gives you a
clue right surround the x-files I
created Union repair software their
special special files right there it's
not a standard okay proprietary is kind
of like the antonym of standard it means
not standard that's the easiest way that
I would say it right so I give an
example for standard okay USB that's a
standard okay that's not proprietary
because everyone uses it okay and it's
not like you have to pay someone a fee
to be able to use USB and your advice if
you want to make like a microphone or
you know a mouse or whatever okay but
proprietary means okay look this am I
didn't bring with me this 30 pin
connector on the end of my my ipod right
its proprietary it's not standard early
Apple can make it if you want to make
him if you want to put them in your
devices which a lot of people do because
it's a big sort of accessories industry
out there accessory market you need to
pay you need to get a license for him
we're not just going to let anyone make
another kind of thing okay now what's
the issue there the issue is control of
data it's very very closely related to
ownership of data okay and this would be
one of the ways that ceramics would say
hey man we earn this data because no one
else can read it no one else knows how
to read it you need a special plugin on
your browser or something like that to
be able to load it up and to interpret
it and to create the files in the first
place okay so they have a control over
the data they're exerting your control
over the data which other people don't
have okay all right lastly is sort of
under all of these and this is the
obvious one basically everyone mentioned
it I'm changing nature of one so again
just like before with what support
emerging trends just don't overstate it
say it say things that are realistic to
the situation like there's all kinds of
new jobs that get created
as a result of this kind of system okay
and some jobs are probably going to
change in their nature right I people
are going to have to interact with ello
23 more after real estate agents are
going to be dealing with emails with
URLs to this kind of thing which they've
got to incorporate into their business
say that rather than people are all
going to lose their jobs and there will
be a crisis or no real estate agents or
stop existing it you don't have to do
that's that's not gonna happen okay so
when you say changing nature of work
being accurate okay don't don't go over
the top so there you go there there's
more than enough issues but can you see
this is the crucial thing I want to get
across to you right how did I go from
what's in the question to the issues I'm
not just sitting there sort of like
meditating tada issues okay I look at
the data may present right it's all bear
it's all there sometimes you have to
extrapolate a little bit of think some
of you might have found once like you
know ownership of data you didn't see
that in the in that first sentence but
it's there that's why they mentioned
that's why I mentioned these groups of
people okay to draw your attention to
that okay so whenever you try to think
issues go back to the question